Divac she's a tank she's an all-star
gamer and she is a force to be reckoned
with in overwatch Chris Watters here
with Mary Kish and GameSpot's overwatch
hero guide Mary let's talk about Deva
and what what's the best way to play her
well you're gonna start with your fusion
cannons and the best part about these
are they have no reload so always be
shooting bang bang bang bang bang bang
bang uh yeah the fusion cannons they're
good in close range though right this is
not something you want to be engaging at
mid distance or across the map she is a
tank
she is meant to be in your face she's
meant to shoot at close range get right
up in their faces and shooting and
getting close before you start cranking
away on the fusion cannons is good
because they do you can move while
you're firing but they slow you down
significantly so you want to get close
and one of the best ways to get close is
use those boosters it's right it has a
really really quick cooldown so use them
all the time use them as soon as you can
as much as you want you also knock
people backwards and you deal damage to
people that you hit if you just plow
right into it and these boosters are key
to the whole philosophy of playing diva
right you are not you know necessarily
waiting in to the front lines and do it
you are darting around to the side you
are flanking you are mixing things up on
the backline you are really causing
trouble for the team that you're facing
because you can boost so frequently and
then once you're up close no one wants
to be up close to a diva that's right
and and you can use that to mess with
the other team in terms of their
positioning as well if they're all
trying to be in one solid formation you
can actually move their tank out of the
way which is really unfortunate or their
healer yeah you need to push someone off
of a point boom get your boosters going
and she's also got the defense matrix
now this as a tank one of your main
priorities is to absorb damage for your
team and the defense matrix is another
way that diva does that because it just
straight up and neutralizes projectiles
yeah it absorbs damage not just from
people's guns but actually a lot of olds
including that horrible Reaper old oh
yeah any any time you start spinning
around just defense matrix and you'll
totally neutralize it Farrah's death
from above so satisfying to just shut
that entire thing down with the defense
matrix and that's also a good way to
help you close distance when you are
trying to when you are moving towards a
character to fire up your fusion cannons
defense matrix on the way in they won't
be able to get you and then you can just
start cranking away
that's right but you can't use your
defense matrix with your fusion cannons
so shooting actually cancels your matrix
so use it with your boosters to move
around without getting hurt but you
can't shoot during that yeah you can
actually cancel both the defense matrix
and the Boosters in case you need to
start shooting someone right away which
is a handy trick now divas alt is
basically to just blow up her entire
mech and cause a lot of problems for
everyone it is a massive damage radius
you can throw your mech into battle by
using boosters and then you hit your alt
actually propels your mech into the fray
and explodes damage that is such a good
trick I remember the first time I did it
successfully it felt so good but yeah
you can you can shoot it alight right on
the ground you can lob it up by a sort
of angling up but using your boosters
with that alt is a great way to catch
people off-guard because it is it does
draw a lot of attention to itself it
starts pulsing and beeping and like you
know everyone gets real alarmed so if
it's moving in on a point or something
like that it's a great way to catch
people with their pants down it's easy
to evade but if you use it with
Reinhardt salt which is earth shatters
okay move or as Arya's Gravitron they're
all sucked in use it then and once
you've used that you are now in divos
alternate form which is like it's just
eva she's running around she's got a gun
the gun could do some decent damage
especially if you're hit scoring
headshots but again she's real squishy
in this mode and you are really just
trying to like get some fire on people
so that your alt comes back and you can
call your mech down yeah her light gun
does damage from a range so go ahead and
stay away from the fray hit people at a
range you uh you get your old really
fast when you're just your diva girl
mode so as long as you're shooting
people you're gonna be able to call your
muck down really fast and when you call
your mech down not only does it push
everyone away it also does damage
someone pushed me off the ledge with the
mech call down and I was so embarrassed
and impressed I wasn't even mad another
embarrassing thing is you can blow
yourself up with that mech so stay away
from it it can hurt you but it won't
hurt your allies all the more reason to
use those boosters so there you have it
that's Deva use those boosters get
around the enemy hairy them shut down
their fire and then blow them all to
smithereens
for more overwatch hero guides keep it
tuned to game spot calm
you